-This is very exciting for me.
It's your first time here.
-It is.
-Also exciting,
we have collaborated
once before.
-We have indeed.
-Yeah.
-You did a little episode
of "This Is Us," didn't you?
-I got to do a cameo
on "This Is Us."
-Yes.
-And it was written so tha
I could play well within
my range as an actor.
-You were --
-I got to play myself.
-You were Seth Meyers.
-Yeah.
-It was a lot of fun, though
-It was so much fun, dude.
You were so great.
You're a better actor than
people give you credit for
-What?
-'Cause people say
a lot of crazy stuff...
-Yeah.
-...behind closed doors.
-Sure, sure, sure.
-But none of it's true.
[ Laughter ]
You're awesome.
Seth's awesome.
-It was really fun,
because we did shoot it
in New York.
We got to hang out the first
time I got to meet you.
And it was good to hang out.
-It was also cool because
it was before I got a chance
to go do "SNL."
-Yes.
-And I talked to you about it.
I was like, "What's it like?
Is it crazy? Is it cool?"
And then I finally got to do it.
It was awesome.
-And you crushed that,
which was fantastic.
-Thank you, man.
It's a blast. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-This movie is wonderful.
-Thank you.
-And it's a departure
from Randall.
-For sure.
-On "This Is Us."
-Which I imagine to some
degree is --
and not just the quality of th
script when you saw it,
but it must be nice to
play something different.
-It's always nice when you get
recognized for a body of wor
than other people just coming up
to you and saying,
"Hey, Randall!"
You love the love that peopl
have for Randall,
but it's always nice when people
know your name and appreciate,
like, the totality of it.
-This is a fantastic film.
And at the same time,
we were talking backstage.
You've been very busy, 'caus
you're shooting "This Is Us,
you're promoting this film
and then, also "Frozen 2."
Congratulations on that.
-Yeah, I'm trying to stomp
for it.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
Hopefully it finds
an audience.
-Yeah --
-Be able to catch on.
I know it had a rough
first weekend. Yeah.
-It's been a tough first week.
I was back there partying with
Anna and Elsa in the snow.
Which was a good time.
[ Laughter ]
-Your kids are eight and four.
-Eight and four.
Yeah, two boys.
-Are they -- are boys that age
are they impressed
with "Frozen 2"?
-Not at all.
-Okay.
-No, listen --
[ Laughter ]
They are impressed by it.
They are not impressed
that I'm in it.
They love the movie.
-Oh.
-They love the music of it
And then I say,
like after it's over,
I was like,
"You think Daddy
did a good job?"
And my 8-year-old was like
"Yeah, you were fine."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Thanks. Thanks, buddy.
I appreciate it."
Fishing for compliments
from your 8-year-old --
That's what I've been
reduced to.
-Do you think that they --
that you take them out of it
They're, you know, they're
in this fantasy land.
They're enjoying it.
-Yeah.
-Then they hear their dad all of
sudden and they're like,
"Oh, this is just a movie.
-That might be a possibility
The 4-year-old loves it.
He's like, "Daddy, that's you.
I can hear you."
-Right.
-So, he gets excited.
The 8-year-old is like, "Lif
should be about me right now."
-Yeah.
-"So, all this attention
that you're gobbling up,
like you got to
spread the wealth, brother,"
so that's where we are.
-But, I mean, pretty good.
For two boys who are eight
and four, you --
not just "Frozen 2," but you
also have "Black Panther."
Is the 8-year-old impresse
with that, as well?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, thank you.
He's impressed with it, bu
here's a note to the wise.
If you take your son to a movi
where the character
that plays your son dies,
he may have a traumatic effect
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah.
So, after, like, when Killmonger
died in the movie,
first time in a movie --
no, "Pete's Dragon" was
the first time he cried
in a movie.
This is the second time,
but he was convulsing.
I had to, like, pick him up,
sit him on my lap,
and rock him and tell him
it was going to be okay.
And afterwards, we go
to the after-party,
he would not leave my side
-Really?
-He's was like, "When are we
going home?
We're going together.
Until then,
I'm not leaving you."
It was beautiful.
It was really, really sweet.
-That's really nice.
-Yeah.
-Also, he was probably
was just a little young.
-Probably. Probably.
We got introduced to
the MCU pretty early.
-Pretty early on.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You -- I also want to ask
about this.
So, your wife, Ryan --
-Yes.
-...also an actress.
-Correct.
-And you met in college?
-We met freshman year
at Stanford University.
-Gotcha.
In the theater program?
-In the theater -- we live
in the same dorm together.
Then we auditioned for our
first play together.
We're both from St. Louis,
Missouri.
-Wow.
-Born in the same hospital
We both then went to NYU
for grad school
and started off with
the same agency,
and then we got married.
-That's fantastic.
-Isn't that crazy?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then I feel like
if enough things line up..
-Yeah. It was like the univers
was saying, like,
"Maybe you guys should
consider it."
-But, is this a true story
Was it her mother, that when
she first saw you on stage
at Stanford, she was not -
-[ Laughs ]
-She had a warning
for your wife.
-She said, "I don't care
who you date here,
just stay away from that boy."
[ Laughter ]
And she pointed at me.
Because we did this
August Wilson play,
"Joe Turner's Come and Gone,
and the character's
very intense,
and I was sort of Methody
at age 18
just trying to inhabit.
And my hair was all scraggly
and looking crazy.
And she's like,
"That Negro, no bueno.
Stay away."
[ Laughter ]
No further way to make sur
that your daughter marries
the man that you don't
want her to end up with.
-Right. You can never rule
anybody out.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Thanksgiving plans this week?
What are you going to do?
-So, we have --
my wife has graciously invited
40 people over to our house.
-Whoa!
[ Audience ohs ]
That's amazing.
-It's really awesome.
-I can't wait
[ Laughter ]
-But is it all family?
'Cause sometimes when it get
to be 40 -- friends as well?
-It's family and friends.
-That's good.
-And it's actually going b
a lot of fun.
We just moved into a new home.
So it's an opportunity to shar
the house with people.
Like, life has been good,
and now we get an chance
to be thankful with family
and friends.
-Well, that's fantastic.
People are very lucky
to have you guys as both
family and friends.
And we are lucky
to have you here.
Thank you so much, man.
-It's been my pleasure, man.
-It's always great to see you.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Sterling K. Brown, everybody.